today on stick to football Conor and I
are back in the studio we're gonna break
down a lot of what we saw in week five
but also we want to look at the
first-year head coaches the rookies who
were out there we had six first-time
head coaches hired this year how are
they performing we're also gonna get
into our first pick scenarios for some
of these teams that are struggling
there's still four winless teams around
the league so we're gonna try to help
those guys out before getting to your
draft on draft questions with Connor
before we jump into the show I have to
remind everyone this Saturday we will be
in Dallas Texas at off-the-cuff again
they're opening up early for us 9:00
a.m. the doors are gonna open we're
gonna do the podcast we're gonna have a
pregame event and then the Texas owe you
game kicks off at 11:30 we're gonna be
there for a watch party so if you want
to come watch the game with us tickets
to this game are ridiculously expensive
look at me across the interstate from
the game watching it with you guys so
definitely hope to see everyone out
there yeah it's gonna be a blast I can't
wait to be at off the cuff obviously
we've had a really good turnout for the
tailgate so it looks like you guys had a
great weekend in Kansas City so things
are going really well with the tailgate
tour and we're excited to see everyone
out there this weekend in Dallas yeah
somebody who's not excited or maybe he
is excited right now let's jump right
into it Jay Gruden gets fired Monday
morning at 5:00 a.m. Eastern time so
4:00 a.m. which is about what time
mellow and I got home from the tailgate
so I was still up with him but we didn't
get a chance to talk about this because
it happens Monday morning I will say
having to kind of cover this story
behind the scenes for the last couple
days you're putting out calls texts to
see if this is something we wanted to
cover on the content side of things with
bleacher report it really sounds like
Jay Gruden is not upset he's gonna get
paid to finish the year his brother's
the head coach in Oakland so he knows he
can go get a job if he needs to get one
but also I think that there is a belief
from people close to Jay they said they
wanted to get out of there before it
completely burnt to the ground because
the stain of this team is not gonna be
on him it's gonna be on Daniel Snyder
and Bruce Allen who's the team president
yeah I look at that as well and I think
this was already unfolding into disaster
territory and it's nice from both sides
that the court is cut I think when
you're looking at this
tuition mad Bruce Allen didn't do
himself any favors in the press
conference I think nobody in this
situation is looking at Jay Gruden and
going wow you screwed this thing up I
think they're going and looking at it
and saying Washington has some serious
organizational issues from the top down
and it could have gotten even worse
actually out of all of this I think I
feel really bad for Dwayne Haskins who
seems to be right in the middle of it it
wasn't wanted by the coaches was wanted
by ownership now there's reports saying
he's not ready and he's struggling
mentally which we know that it hasn't
been an issue with him in the past so
this is a disaster I'm curious to see
where Jay Gruen ends up because I know
when there was some rumors going around
that he could be fired after last year
and he survived that teams that were
looking for head coaches really liked
him so I don't think this is the end of
Jay Gruden maybe not as a head coach
next year but I think like you said Matt
he has a lot of job security even in
other roles around the league yeah I
think he's gonna be just fine and and
all I did one thing I have heard as some
name starts to leak out I know some
people have said Mike Tomlin with how
poorly the Steelers are doing it might
be a situation where he could jump to
Washington to kind of start over but I
wanted to throw this name at you Kevin
O'Callahan who was a third round pick by
the Patriots back in the day didn't
really last in the NFL but he's been
coaching in the league after being a
private quarterbacks coach he's been in
the league since 2015 he's had a very
fast rise up the ladder there's a lot of
people that are already saying this
might be that next not Sean McVeigh but
that next young higher where teams
really want to get ahead of instead of
wait around for and I did something I
talked about when with Sean McVeigh got
hired something I talked about with Matt
nag he got hired as well
teams would rather hire these offensive
minds a year too early instead of a year
too late and let them grow on the job a
little bit yeah it's interesting cuz
O'Connell is only 34 years old he's
gonna take over the play calling you
know he's been developing there so it is
really this is almost like a Freddy
kitchens trial doesn't it feel that way
again Matt yeah in like Freddie kitchens
not the interim head coach but the
retaining his offensive coordinator
title yeah and I think it is a little
bit of an audition to see what he can do
how the players
to him how he interacts with with
ownership so that that is a big one we
had two very good primetime games
Sunday night again Melo and I recorded
before the game because we were at a
tailgate so we didn't get a reaction to
Sunday Night Football and then Monday
Night Football which was an absolute
beatdown but there is a lot to talk
about on and off the field with these
two games especially that Niners Browns
game but I want to quickly go back to
what happened Sunday night when you're
in the stadium like it's sometimes hard
to get the perspective of what's what's
happening in the bigger picture you
almost live play to play you know you
get caught up in the atmosphere of the
game so going back and watching this
game yesterday watching the the
condensed version of this on NFL game
past I could not believe how well the
Colts offensive line dominated the
Chiefs defensive line at Chris Jones and
Frank Clark need that they need to step
up and I know Jones is banged up right
now but my goodness like I I was shocked
at how well the Colts just controlled
the line of scrimmage that was the
biggest takeaway from me in this one I
think when you look at the cults because
of the way they built the team in the
trenches on the offensive side of the
ball they could play with anyone that's
what happens when you build that kind of
offensive line now Marlon Mac deserves a
lot of credit the turnaround of this
player I mean when we watched him coming
out of college he always had the outside
speed but now the patience the vision
the ability to break tackles he looks
like a different player to me Matt and I
think I don't want to harp on this too
much but you wonder if this team had
Andrew Luck would they be you know maybe
the best team or a top two team in the
AFC I don't know Jake hope he's doing a
fine job
I think this win for the Colts just
shows that they're not going anywhere
because they have such a key foundation
where it matters most
yeah they absolutely do and it is up
front it reminds me of how Dallas built
and they didn't reach you know super
high levels but they built a really good
offensive line and it helped turnaround
that franchise I think that's where we
see the Colts are right now and for the
Chiefs I think two weeks in a row we've
seen mahomes look human to some degree
there was the play where he's like
running around for his life and then
threw a touchdown pass so not completely
human but closer to human and I think
some of that will help
once Eric Fisher's back once Tyree kills
back the offense just does not look the
same right now and they look bigs are
disjointed Cameron Irving is obviously
not a left tackle and I think that's a
big part of the issue right now it's
just problem I think getting Fischer
back is really like an untalked about
story especially being somewhat local in
Kansas City everyone's like panicking
about the defense but the offense has
been slowed down in the last two weeks
which is why I mean they did beat
Detroit but that's why they lost you
know Sunday night not being able to
score any points so I don't think the
sky is falling in Kansas City you score
13 points it's really the first bad
offensive performance of the mahomes era
I think they're gonna be just fine but
when you look at how that the defensive
line I mean you have guys that are
getting paid up there you need Chris
Jones who's getting a new contract you
need Frank Clark we need to see those
guys start to make bigger more
consistent plays and and I'll say you
got to throw something on the
linebackers too because they Marlon Mac
it was just picking his spots all night
long the Chiefs could do nothing to stop
him so and as soon as you get you know
the box loaded and that happened you see
honey badger walk down then Jacoby
percent has these very high percentage
throws over the top so a little
disappointing for our Chiefs fans out
there I know we got a lot of Colts fans
who are very happy about that win though
someone else who's very happy dude
teni very happy last night watching
reasons multiple reasons not only was it
great to see the Niners continue to be
undefeated for know the only undefeated
team in the NFC at this point it was
great to see guys like Matt Breda on a
national stage you know break out and
show that I think there's this
perception of who he is that's not who
he is like he is a home run hitter he's
one of the fastest running backs in
football that's what they've built here
Tevin Coleman had almost 100 yards it
was just a it was like an old-school
Niners game but Nick Bosa absolutely
trolling Baker Mayfield Richard
Sherman's comments after the game and
then the fact that I Baker continues to
struggle this is something we haven't
talked about on the show because I think
we wanted to wait and see what happened
you don't want to be that guy that say
jumping on a player who has one bad game
but now we are four games in and the
Browns have been incredibly inconsistent
last night Baker is eight of 22
for a hundred yards two interceptions
one not entirely his fault the past in
Antonio Callaway it wasn't a great throw
but it really should have been caught
but just a really really bad night for
Baker Mayfield across the board I mean
that the Niners were able to get after
him
four times they sacked him and a lot of
those were him holding the ball too long
in the pocket that's the problem for me
Matt he keeps drifting away from
pressure or whether the offensive line
holds up or not he does not have the
trust in them where he's drifting
himself into sacks or bad throws and I
think when it comes down to it for me I
look at this Browns team there are
struggles in a lot of key areas the
offensive line being one Baker being a
huge one I think there was a lack of
targets at times for Odell which we've
seen his play really drift away when
he's not involved the identity Nick
Chubb needs to be the identity of this
offense I think that's very important
you know miles Garrett is still a great
player but there's only so much he could
do and credit to the Niners I did not
think this team would have this kind of
star and they've just been phenomenal
the play calling has been great the
defensive line looks like the best in
football right now they're getting early
returns from Nick Powe so they have a
lot of talent around him I think Mike
McDaniel deserves a ton of credit for
the run game that he's calling right now
in his second year as their run
coordinator and there's a reason why
Kyle Shanahan blocked him from taking OC
jobs elsewhere like the Packers to go
work with Lafleur so I look at this
Niners team right now and it's clicking
and this is a big win for them this is
their biggest win of the season I don't
think there's there should be reasons to
doubt them and then you look back at
Baker if you want to you know talk that
kind of talk all offseason and things
start out on a wrong note there's gonna
be people that clap back there's people
that remember it from college that's
Nick Bosa there's people of veterans
that have been doing this a long time in
the NFL and don't like the [ __ ]
that's Richard Sherman and I like Baker
but I think the act might have worn out
a little too much and I think it's time
to put up some points and win some
football games a little more
consistently well yeah and let's start
at pregame because I actually didn't
catch this
I got home neither did i right at
kickoff basically and so I I don't know
if this was covered on the broadcast you
someone should I actually want to know
so please tweet us if this was covered
on the pregame broadcast Richard Sherman
says the Baker Mayfield refused to shake
their hand before the game and I want to
be fair and balanced here when when the
Kansas players did this to Baker
Mayfield I went off it was like that's
petty that's chicken [ __ ] like come on
have some respect for your opponent have
some respect for the man across the
field from you because you never know
like you especially in the NFL you could
be on that guy's team next year you know
it's just oh yeah don't act like that
and so to do that is just incredibly
disrespectful so in Kansas did it I
thought it was justified when Baker went
off and he's grabbing his crotch and
yelling across the field I understand
that he felt disrespected and acted out
but then to turn around two years later
and to do that to a professional a
hall-of-famer like Richard Sherman a
player that's just classless and to
think what you want about Richard
Sherman I have not I've interacted with
him a lot throughout my career which it
runs about the same length as his he has
always been classy thoughtful respectful
and I would have said this when he was a
Seahawk I'm not just saying this because
he plays my favorite team we used to do
stuff with him early be our video all
the time I always had a great time with
Richard Sherman he was so approachable
and helpful and so for Baker Mayfield I
understand you want a competitive edge
and like the juices are flowing there's
a time and place to be competitive and
when that man is like trying to shake
your hand before the game I just feel
like that is really really tacky for
Baker Mayfield to now take something
that he thought was a slight you know
two years ago and now he's doing it to
someone else that just doesn't feel fair
to me yeah it wasn't a great move I
thought George Kittel had an interesting
take on it you know Kittles was kind of
like well that's his alternate persona
that he creates and you know we all of
our ways we get ourselves immersed
before the game and Kidal didn't really
seem to mind it but at the same time
Kittel is a guy that is a very
interesting character and he's also one
of the best tight ends in football and
that's as a blocker and as a pass
catcher and he could do whatever the
hell he wants because every
Sunday George Kittel is one of the best
tight ends in football Baker Mayfield
right now is not one of the best
quarterbacks in the NFL he's not a
top-ten quarterback this year he I don't
think he's been a top 20 quarterback and
I want Baker to be great but at some
point and I don't want him to change who
he is
but it feels like there's been a little
extra sauce since Oklahoma because he
knew the situation he was walking to in
Cleveland I think his you know working
with Freddie Freddie allows him to be
who he is which is great but at the end
of the day at some point do you turn it
down well just a little bit you don't
have to be Matt Ryan you know what I
mean you don't have to do the Aaron
Rodgers you could be Aaron Rodgers but
man like it's just it's crazy to me that
it comes to this where so much of Baker
is about all these things that he's
doing that don't have to do with
football anymore and I think it's almost
taking away from the player he can be
that we know he could be well and I said
this summer because this was a hot topic
all summer and I said I don't care if
Baker talks if they win if they went if
you're gonna be the guy that talks and
he's disrespectful and you're losing
it's probably not gonna work for you for
very long so I don't know if he tones it
down I don't it's not working like what
they're doing in Cleveland is just not
working and and like on the other side
of this I don't want me to sell about
Baker their defense should not be as bad
as they are greedy Williams being out
did some work being out or being hurt at
least it hurts that does that affects it
a lot but their defense should not be as
bad everyone's managers yeah exactly
got him find me a team is healthy right
now so all right let's take a break when
we come back we're gonna look at those
winless teams we're look at these
undefeated teams and run through the
rookie head coaches it is time to look
at the winless teams there four of them
and the teams that have lost there are
two of them now he's starting to get
paired down I actually think a fun
question do you think we'll have a
winless team longer or an undefeated
team longer winless yeah so we're gonna
we're gonna lose one of these
unfortunately after this weekend because
the Redskins play the doll
I'm not being a hater because I do think
they've out proven my expectations I
think the Niners got to lose eventually
right they're not going undefeated yeah
I mean that I mean let's see okay I
think Sam I think the Niners lose to the
Rams this weekend I will say this light
and I'm everyone knows I'm a Niners fan
they have outplayed my expectations I
picked them to go eight and eight I
think yeah they haven't played anyone
yet I'll be that guy
I mean they beat Tampa Cincinnati the
Steelers and the Browns those are not
good football teams now they dominated
last night they looked really good I
think they would have beat if you play
like that you're gonna be almost anybody
with the turnovers a couple lucky breaks
a great pass rush the Rams game this
weekend is gonna be it's gonna be
amazing
III do think we have a windless team
much much longer
the Jets play the Cowboys this weekend
and then the Patriots and then the
Patriots so the Jets could easily be
Owen six easily and then you have the
Jags you're gonna run into men shoe
mania this will hopefully Sam spleen is
back to normal by that November ease
convert I don't expect the Jets to win
at least compete in games the bengals
have the ravens Jags rams and ravens in
that stretch yeah
the Bengals are at [ __ ] bengals are
in serious winless territory this year
oh yeah yeah there's gonna be there's be
some - and 14s out there when it's all
said and done we talked about the
Redskins they fired their head coach
obviously it's just in disarray there
right now bill Callahan the interim head
coach says they're gonna go with either
Colt McCoy or Case Keenum we're not
gonna see join Haskins this year the
Dolphins I will at least defend the
Dolphins because they tried to do this
plan they're gonna have three
first-round picks this is what they
wanted to do they want it to tank so the
Dolphins like you almost congratulate
them because they're doing what they
tried to do the bengals however they did
not try to do this they did not plan to
be Owen five and when you look at
bengals the only guy they're missing is
AJ Green so like I will say this I was
never a fan of Zach Taylor being a head
coach this soon I thought he's in way
over his head especially for a front off
a team excuse me it doesn't have a
traditional front office structure with
like you know your GM and then all your
lieutenants this is a very unique setup
that they haven't Cincinnati and I I
think it requires a very strong head
coach they play the Ravens like you said
the Jags the Rams the Ravens then the
Raiders and we could head into
Thanksgiving with the Bengals not
winning a football game yeah we
definitely can we definitely can I think
they took a gut punch early on by losing
Jonah Williams for the year I think when
Zach Taylor came in it was hey I'm gonna
rebuild this offensive line
I got a running back in place I'll
figure out the quarterback and see if
he's the future or if not but they've
they definitely are they're in number
one pict territory Miami wants to be
watch them beat the Redskins this week
and end up picking like third overall
right that would be unbelievable the
Jets you know I'm not making excuses
they are bad and they're poorly coached
but they should be getting their
quarterback back soon
CJ Mosley's their best offensive player
he should be back soon
I think they sneaked out you know
they're gonna sneak out wins they're not
gonna be a winless team and if I'm wrong
fire me to the moon I don't know what to
say but it there's a lot of bad teams
right now Matt that's the key point and
I think something that we're gonna do
later in this show is we're gonna figure
out what do these teams do at the top of
the draft with so much talent versus
quarterback need with a lot of these bad
teams yeah and I think with the Jets
they are poorly coached and I think you
could throw the Jets you could throw the
Bengals in here his team's with first
year head coaches rookie head coaches
that we are going to talk about and
let's just transition there right now
actually because what do you do like and
I'll ask you as a Jets fan yeah are you
guys just over Adam GaSe or does he get
a pass because Sam Darnell's been hurt
because the the former front office did
not do a good job of building an
offensive line I think that's fair to
say at this point you you're out you
know some talent at receiver let me up
bail does look amazing but they're like
some big problems here that are not a
quick fix it's hard to win with your
practice squad quarterback right like
Luke Falk has been far and away the
worst quarterback in football this year
threw a couple games at the same time
if you didn't believe in the higher in
the first place
and the team looks lifeless you know why
and Joe Douglas has a six-year deal Adam
GaSe has a four-year deal Joe has the
power to pull the plug and get his own
guy I don't care how many rumors there
are that they're friends right I would
be over it I personally would I would go
get somebody more creative or that has
hasn't been given a shot yet and I'm
just not a believer that Adam GaSe is
the guy I never necessarily was but at
the same time he's been Delta raw hands
and nobody's gonna be winning these
games I mean look at what Kyle Shanahan
lost 12 games when he lost his
quarterback so it's a raw deal for Adam
GaSe but I I mean I'd be ready to move
on anyway just because I don't believe
in the higher yeah yeah I liked the
higher but I liked the higher with the
idea that that they weren't pushing the
reset button
I don't think Adam GaSe you gotta build
a team with like if I if you're gonna
rebuild and I mean when you start on
five you're rebuilding or owing for that
you're rebuilding you're not making the
playoffs it's a rebuilding here so I
think you look at that like god I would
rather have someone else anyone else
almost to build a team with especially
to Institute culture and to set up
accountability and structure that's just
not Adam GaSe I thought he was someone
who was more coming in to try to get
this team over the hump like I would
look at someone like Sean McDermott as a
good example of what the Jets need
yeah great leader hired a really good
staff yeah you look at what Dave was
doing there on the offense
McDermott could do everything else he's
coaching a top defense he's a good
leader I think he has had good influence
on personnel decisions and I think he
hired the right offensive coordinator to
make it work yeah so I think it on that
yeah I'm with that as well and I think a
team that has taken that bills model as
the Miami Dolphins with Brian Flores he
walks into a job like McDermott where
you don't expect to win a lot of games I
walk into a job where you don't be a
franchise quarterback yet and you walk
into a job where this team's gonna be
built on the back end of their defense
so the heels of their defense and you
know it's hasn't been pretty yet but can
we even judge Bryan Flores right now
Matt no I don't think we can and I'm
glad that the football media hasn't like
rushed to been like up Bryan Flores is
out it's not safe
this was the plan as long as Steven Ross
is still on board owner Steven Ross as
long as he's still signing those checks
and saying this is the plan you're gonna
have three picks probably in the top 15
you're definitely up to in the top ten
right now we're okay with this
this is what we want to do we're gonna
get a quarterback we're gonna get a pass
rusher or a receiver we're good with it
then Chris Greer the GM and Brian Flores
are safe they're fine and I think I want
someone in the AFC East to be smart
enough to go we're not beating New
England until Tom Brady retires so
instead of trying to go six and ten or
seven and nine we're gonna do what Miami
did we're gonna tear this [ __ ] down and
it might take three years but in three
years Tom Brady will be gone so we will
be hitting our peak right when Brady's
gone and there will be a void in the AFC
East I don't know if the Dolphins are
that smart I like to think that they are
because I think Chris Greer is a really
really intelligent guy and I want to see
them succeed
so I hope that's what they're doing is
let's look at the timing of this because
you can't beat the Patriots at their own
game no one has been able to
consistently do it so why not start
loading up for a future after them
basically yeah that's how I think the
Dolphins are looking at this thing where
I don't think they're pigeon holds into
taking a quarterback next year I think
in at the end of things if they pick
number one they'll take two uh but I
think they could take a chase young and
use those other assets on an offensive
line and build out a team but they won't
be in the panic mode where 2020 is hey
you better win seven eight nine games I
don't think the Dolphins are in that
kind of position right now I really do
think this is a three-year plan and I
have a feeling that Zach Taylor and
Cincinnati will be given the same luxury
yeah I feel like Zach might be safer
than expected again because because of
that unconventional front-office style
that they have there where you're you're
not gonna get the GM who feels the
pressure to make a move to save his own
job it's the owner basically like they
they're running everything I know Duke
Tobin has a lot of power but there's not
your conventional structure here so I
think that allows them some flexibility
on the other side of this you know I've
actually been really surprised with Matt
Lafleur I was not a huge fan of that
hire and I don't think their offense has
played particularly
well but they're winning ball games
therefore wins it's hard to be upset
about a team that is four and one right
now and just beat the Dallas Cowboys so
no offense they're ranked 13th in points
25th in yards which is not great when
you hire a guy who's a quote-unquote
offensive mastermind but as long as
they're winning ball games and they're
doing it you know I think Mike Patton's
defense has been very good so far this
year really good as long as they're
winning ball games I don't know that
anyone's gonna care that and we just saw
Aaron Jones run all over a Dallas
Cowboys team that was expected to be
really strong in the front seven yeah I
think you look at this Dallas team right
now they need some help on that
defensive line in the trenches right now
and for the you know credit to the
Packers for Lafleur because half of this
battle with this job was getting along
with Aaron Rodgers and keeping him happy
and his team is winning games and I
think Aaron Rodgers is pretty damn happy
about that yeah I think he is too yeah
and and has to be a Roger so I throw one
pick this year which is huge like when I
look at why are they winning they're not
turning the ball over and they're the
ball exactly and and it's lightly so
simple but it's so beautiful couple guys
in the middle Kliff Kingsbury got his
first win congratulations that wasn't a
tie and I think we're seeing Clift like
he's he's being very aggressive and I
like that but this is still a bad team
that's probably not gonna win many more
ballgames Freddie kitchens we talked
about really continues to struggle the
biggest surprise of the six rookie head
coaches for me is this one Vic Fangio
has one win through five weeks I did not
expect that
I really thought like this is the best
defensive coordinator in football and
you're gonna give him von Miller at the
time Bradley Chubb you have Chris Harris
jr. in the backend like this should have
been a good team a veteran quarterback
their offensive line is absolutely
terrible and they're just not able to
get anything going offensively I think
it's why we're seeing them continue to
struggle yeah I think when you go back
to cliff he's in the Zach Taylor mould
where if you hire a coach that young
that's an offense of mind for a team
that needs to be gutted almost and
rebuilt
you're gonna stay patient and give that
a three year window
I don't think Vic gets that window mat
he's 61 years old there was a lot of
question marks around the hire as great
as the defensive mind he was there's
question marks about
flacco and the future quarterback with
this team I think for the Broncos they
have been even worse than shredding
water but when you look at the roster
right now they are the classic tread
water franchise and I think at some
point you need to start fresh get a
coach in there that's gonna rebuild this
offense and really get back to the way
the game is going right now and that you
know they've drafted better over the
years after some really bad years of
trafficking but I just don't think
Fangio is gonna be given this crazy kind
of leash and let's not forget they're in
a division with the Chiefs the Chargers
who yeah they just lost but whatever and
the Raiders are looking a lot better the
Broncos are the team that's falling
behind absolutely our man and you're
right the Raiders like I could not
believe they beat the Bears and to beat
them the way they did so yeah it is that
time of year where it's like you have to
be careful because if you have started
winless you're not making the playoffs
it is a statistical impossibility
basically at this point no team has ever
done it one team the 92 charger started
on four it made the playoffs no one has
ever started on five and made it so if
you are one of those teams we mentioned
before that's winless it's not gonna be
great how about the Patriots and Niners
though I know we've talked about the
Niners a lot on the show but the
Patriots are honestly a little bit of a
surprise to me that they remain
undefeated they're not getting tight in
production the defense though has just
been absolutely amazing and they've
overcome a lot of injuries on the
offensive line already it's almost
unfair how well this team just continues
to roll despite whatever gets thrown in
front of them you know Antonio Brown
[ __ ] who cares they're still the
third best offensive football in terms
of points but the defense they are
allowing six point eight points per game
you will win every game in the NFL if
you can do that that's the key right
there for me I think this defense has
even picked up Tom Brady and is one bad
outing at Buffalo yep and we talked
about how good that Buffalo defense is I
think New England is the classic case of
you know they lose something somewhere
like you said tight end production this
year and you know they were at receiver
at times but they've had guys step up
and they find a way to make it work
elsewhere the offense looks a little
weaker the defense gets ultimately much
so this is what New England does and as
long as Bill Belichick is there
I think they'll always find a way to
patch up their holes while regenerating
elsewhere yep that's that's how they're
amazing they know their team better than
anyone else in the NFL and they play to
the strengths of it so the Patriots
schedule is tough I don't think we're
gonna see them go undefeated by any
stretch but they have the Giants the
Jets the Browns the Ravens in their next
four we could see them start 9 - no I
don't think that's it yeah the Baltimore
is the only team that really scares me
there yeah and they've kind of been
figured out I know they're one Sunday
but I think they've been a little bit
figured out the past few weeks so it'll
be seemly fun to watch I'm sorry it's
boring the Patriots are once again
really good at football let's take a
break we come back we'll rip through
these first pick scenarios for the worst
teams in the NFL I mentioned there are
some bad teams in the NFL right now the
good news of your bad team is you're
gonna get a good pick in the NFL Draft
which it's already draft season
especially if you're a fan of the
Bengals Redskins Dolphins Jets Broncos
probably the Falcons as well there's
just some not great football being
played we want to run through some
scenarios let's start here at number one
is where the Cincinnati Bengals are
currently projected to be because they
the strength of schedule is the worst of
the teams without a win their strength
the schedules the weakest so they would
have the first pick the Bengals on the
clock if they finish with the first pick
they're going to draft to a technophile
oh they can't not it doesn't matter like
Andy Dalton
I don't think Andy's that bad of a
quarterback but he's definitely not that
good of a quarterback if you have a
chance to just start over a quarterback
you have to do it yeah and you're out of
the money in Dalton's contract soon
where this is the perfect time and it's
not like Andy Dalton is 24 years old
where you're saying hey we think he'll
get a lot better you go with the player
in this draft that can be a franchise
passer and really set the tone for this
brand of Bengals football that's coming
in with Zach Taylor running the show you
know what I mean Matt they need an
identity right now that's what the
Bengals don't have and I think when you
have Jonah Williams coming back next
year you can argue hey we feel like we
have the offensive line going in the
right direction for
rookie quarterback to come in here and
thrive yeah it is I do believe that with
the Bengals like they getting jonah back
they have Tyler Boyd who they really
believe in at the receiver position they
like Joe Mixon I think it has to be
quarterback here I will say chase Young
is gonna make things very difficult for
all these teams drafting early if you
don't need a quarterback chase Young is
by far the most impactful player I still
think Gerry Judy's a great wide receiver
prospect but chase young being an edge
rusher that's a premium position so I do
think even teams like the Bengals are
gonna have to have a long conversation
about this it's like what miles Garrett
17 draft miles Garrett was so good and
the Browns were so bad at evaluating I
think we have to throw that in there
that Patrick mahomes in deshaun Watson
and Mitchell Tripp whiskey go after the
pass rusher so it will be something to
watch this year the Redskins right now
would have the number two pick I don't
believe they're going to give up on
Dewayne Haskins I think this front
office does like him quite a bit
obviously they drafted him last year a
new head coach might want to roll with
their own guy but I don't see a
quarterback being the pick for the
Redskins in 2020 they drafted Montez
sweat in the first round last year they
haven't seen a ton of production from
him
I think chase young makes sense here
Jerry Judy absolutely makes sense here
Judy and Terry Maclaurin would be one of
the most fun young wide receiver duo's
in football so when I look at the
Redskins it's like okay Ryan Kerrigan is
getting older so chase young could be a
need but he's definitely a fit based on
value he's just so good that I would
project him to be better than Kerrigan
and sweat so it really doesn't matter
who you have on the roster if this guy
could be better I'm gonna go on the
other side of the ball for Washington
and say that with the rise of Terry
McClaren and obviously maybe even Calvin
Harmon a little bit there that they can
take chase young in the spot build out
that front seven get a premier pass
rusher you don't know what you have in
Montez sweat you're not going to wait to
find out you're gonna take the guy that
you can believe can be the Miles Garrett
potentially of this draft class and just
go get somebody that gets after the
quarterback for you and defends the run
as well as anyone non-stop there in
Washington from what will be a new head
coaching staff number three the Miami
Dolphins they actually currently pick at
number
seven right now as well thanks to that
Steelers trade for Mika Fitzpatrick so
at three and seven they have some
flexibility here now the Houston Texans
pick would be a little bit later I
believe right now would be in the early
20s so they have three picks in round
one but I think when you look at three
this is a team when we talked about this
earlier they are all in on a quarterback
I I know that everyone kind of we'll see
what happens with Josh Rosen they did
trade a not a Premier pick but they
traded an early enough pick for him that
you you would think you would want to
wait and see where it goes with the rest
of this year but I think just right now
not projecting what happens with Rosen
or how he looks right now I would feel
like quarterback will be a priority I
don't like any of the other quarterbacks
after twoa enough to draft one here this
like me personally I'm not drafting
Justin Herbert in the top ten
Joe burrow I like a lot but not at three
you know guys like Jalen Hurd's Jake
from Jacob east and Jacob Eason really
struggled this past weekend like there's
just there are too many question marks
for any of those guys to draft them at
three so I think the Dolphins actually
end up in a spot here a lot like the
Redskins we're okay if you're not
drafted a quarterback it does become
chase young or Jerry Judy because
they're the other two premier players in
this class and it's a class in which I
feel like they're about five really good
players after that there's a pretty big
drop-off yeah I think so too and I think
the Dolphins will also have to kind of
take into account how do we want to
rebuild this offensive line and we want
to look at Tristan works so we want to
look at Andrew Thomas you know how do we
want to rebuild that unit maybe they do
that with the second pick they have in
this trap that is the Steelers pick
which is looking like it could be a
top-10 pick so the Dolphins have a
really interesting choice on their hands
yeah no they they absolutely do and I
think so do your Jets who would pick
number four right now see where it gets
very interesting and here's what where
I'll say the draft does not line up well
for the justice sure we've seen this
team good luck in the past Jamal Falls
to them Leo Falls to them Quinlan sauce
them it's not good this year
yeah evened Arnold it's not good this
year that I guess what you could really
hope for is that Jerry Judi Falls and
that they were just like okay well let's
just get Sam a true number one receiver
that doesn't solve the left tackle
problem it doesn't solve the fact that
there is no outside pass rush an AJ up
Anessa a player I really like he's not a
fit for what they want to do on the air
she's six foot six 285 pounds yeah he's
almost gonna play he would play inside
here they don't need that it would be
redundant so I think it actually doesn't
play well for the Jets who have to hope
and pray that Tristan wharfs or Andrew
Thomas over the next three months really
emerges and looks like a guy who could
be a top five picket tackle yeah I think
you nailed it Matt I think they're in a
really weird spot here I think offensive
line I'll be huge and I think at the
same time like you said you got to start
getting your prayer your prayer sheet
out and hope Jerry Judi Falls to this
spot unless you believe at E Hagins or a
CD Lam can go this early but you look at
the Jets and they got to rebuild this
offensive line I mean it's they're gonna
lose guys the free agency they haven't
been that good anyway and I don't know
if they'll be picking top five will be
very curious to see how things shake out
when D'Arnot is back but man Joe Douglas
has a lot of work to do in his first
offseason with this team
yeah and thankfully they have a lot of
money they're gonna be able to be
aggressive that way but they they do
need they need some work buddy number
five the Denver Broncos again until we
do expect to be this high they need a
left tackle the gara bulls experiment
experience was a bad one it just is not
working I don't think they'll go
quarterback here I think they are a team
that this is where I believe that
Jeffrey a CUDA start talk starts
probably with the Jets at four yeah it
does
the Broncos would have to consider him
as well Chris Harris jr. we don't know
how much longer he'll be in Denver so I
think Corner becomes very interesting
here I've said before I like kakuta more
than I liked didn't so Ward I like him
more than I liked Marshawn Lattimore
he's he's one of the best corners I've
seen in the last five or six years he's
just that talented yeah he's a great
cover corner the way he plays the ball
he's got you know great hips good speed
good length he really checks every box
it's almost like you just want to see
more of him to keep riding the same
notes and be like okay yeah he's exactly
what I thought and that's a top ten
player and then the Broncos at the same
time say they win a handful more games
Matt when do they fall into the
conversations of the Joe burrows the
Jacob Easons of the worlds these
quarterbacks where you go well they have
all the talent or did they just take a
guy like that Andrew Luck and last
year's draft I think they kind of did
and I almost feel like we've got seen a
180 on drew lock unfortunately we're now
people are like oh I didn't really like
him but it's just been a hurt he hasn't
played it's not his fault that he had a
thumb injury in the preseason so I feel
like they would they would roll with
Drew lock still I don't think Elway
wants to give up on that I know they
really liked him and I liked Drew lock
as well I I thought that he was
definitely worthy of where they picked
him he's worth developing and seeing
where he's at so I feel like they owe it
to him to wait and see but that does I
mean it does make it interesting because
here we are picked number six and we're
like okay one quarterbacks come off the
board into a I the Falcons are drafted
one the Dolphins at seven well they
would just draft the guy at three if
they really liked them so there are a
lot of teams that need quarterbacks
they're mostly picking in that like nine
to twenty range right now you know the
the teams that need quarterback trade up
yeah I think we could see a good amount
of trade up this year where especially
like you know the I feel like the
Chargers are a team where they're
interesting enough that like could they
try to draft a quarterback to the future
maybe they like east and stick you know
the Titans at 13 the Bucs at 14 they
need upgrades at quarterback you know
what are we gonna see Carolina do what
are we gonna see Jacksonville then
obviously wouldn't draft quarterbacks
but if they go with their young guys
that could put Nick Foles on the market
it could put Cam Newton on the market
which would then yeah Jameis Winston
might be on the market yeah I mean it's
who knows no I mean and even a
Pittsburgh you know I mean after
watching Mason Rudolph struggle at times
you know I think anyone's gonna struggle
with that offense right now with how
they're playing but and after taking
that terrifying hit on Sunday you know
the Steelers could be a team it's like
okay well we need to start thinking
about a quarterback of the future
because that guy didn't get it done they
traded Josh Dobbs
so maybe the Steelers would be a team
that would surprise us but I do think
this year the draft is gonna be the wide
receiver class is amazing there's a lot
of quarterbacks to evaluate and there's
a couple good defenders this doesn't
look like it's gonna be that super top
heavy draft where there's 12 names that
we're all geeked about I think there's
five names probably you know chase young
Jerry Judy to a evanesce and Jeffery
CUDA are the guys swear I'm like okay
that's five guys I'm pretty excited
about after that I think
a lot of good players who are still
trying to prove themselves to some
degree that's exactly right it's about
premium talent and you know those names
come off the board in those first couple
pics and at the end of the day then you
get into the the 20 to 40 range kind of
players where they're all the same yeah
yeah all the same Conor tailgated too
hard this weekend that's let's take a
break when we come back we're gonna get
to your guys draft on draft questions
there's a lot of good ones this week it
is trapped on draft time time to get
through all your questions of the week
and the first one ice water
only okay that's one way to live that's
what I should have done this weekend
how much has JK Dobbins stock gone up I
understand there's Taylor up in
Wisconsin and Swift in UGA but JK has
been running hard all season while
averaging seven yards per carry yeah I
tweeted about this a little bit on
Sunday morning no running back has moved
up for me like JK Dobbins has this year
and I think we're seeing him play better
on third down especially which is key
he just looks stronger and faster this
year I thought last year he really got
showed up by Mike Webber and going back
to his freshman year he's just in such
better shape now and it shows with you
know like the breakaway run that he had
on Saturday I don't think he's doing
that as a freshman so I think JK Dobby
was a stock way up he's he's my number
four running back right now but that
means a round to pick so I think that's
a really good spot for Dobbins to be
yeah he's had a great bounce-back year I
mean you pretty much have been showing
you everything you could have asked of
him after being just okay last year all
right team are troopers is Minshew or
Kyle Allen more likely to remain the
starter when the original quarterbacks
come back healthy gosh this is really
tough I'd be talking about it every week
too right
I do feel like it's Gardner Minshew
because you can sit Nick Foles without
as many questions as sitting Cam Newton
Cam Newton has I mean he is really
rejuvenated football in the Carolinas
like he is the face of that team Nick
Foles and I never like played that much
for the Jaguars so I don't know if that
is an issue where you're like oh my god
they just paid him I know Melo said this
a couple shows go
the Seahawks payed Matt Flynn once and
benched him for Russell Wilson that
worked out okay so I think kalons
playing well I do want to tip
captain he's playing well he has that
team executing beautifully Christian
McCaffrey taking off I would like to see
both of them keep the job but I think
Minshew is the one that's much more
likely to keep it all right 60 Football
Hall of Fame member Patrick Chamberlain
on a scale of one to ten how worried are
you about the performance of the
following quarterbacks so far this year
Jared Goff Baker Mayfield mr. Biscay
Trevor Lawrence as the last one
Wow so I'm not worried about golf
because I we've seen golf play well and
quarterbacks go through peaks and
valleys a little bit so I would say with
golf I like it three he's gonna be fine
I even thought in that loss to Seattle
that he had a lot of really good throws
their defense just did not play very
well and Russell Wilson's Russell Wilson
I am creative worried about Baker
Mayfield because I think what we're
seeing from him like weird talked about
earlier he's not stepping up in the
pocket he's falling back into this old
habit of he's always going to his right
he's always drifting D coordinators have
picked up on that and they're gonna
continue to pick up on that like last
night they're flushing him so hard to
his right and then they're just cleaning
it up with delayed pressure that's not
hard to do I mean we can sit here and
scheme that up so imagine what a
defensive coordinator in the NFL is
gonna do so I'm Baker I would say I'm at
like a six mid strabinsky I'm at a ten
like I'm all the way worried about a
scary key and I'm worried about Matt
naggy who was I was very out front and
you know saying I thought that's who
they should hire it's just not working
there right now even pre-injury with
Trevor Lawrence I'm not worried at all
it's like a one I guess a zero because
he's a sophomore this happens I remember
and I've talked about this a lot I
remember watching Jared Goff struggle in
college he was still first pick of the
draft
I remember watching Josh Allen struggle
he was still a top-10 pick and I think
that's something that I will say about
all these guys it one bad game for the
quarterback doesn't worry me actually
said this to Melo Sunday going to Kansas
City we've been so spoiled by Tom Brady
though we don't expect quarterbacks to
have bad games anymore because like
Brady just doesn't really ever have a
shitty game and it cost the team and if
he has over the last 19 years I think
they're not memorable now when a
quarterback struggles were like you're
not supposed to do this Aaron Rodgers
struggle but like Brady has been so
great the the bar is set super high for
quarterback play even
argaï mahomes like he's had to kind of
average games back to back he looks
human freaking out yeah but he's still
are you still really really good he's
probably still the MVP like let's let's
just chill a little bit yeah especially
for Trevor Lawrence who just celebrated
his 20th birthday last weekend that's
how young the guy is all right Dustin
Lackey with everything going on with
Washington do you think that Dwayne
Haskins turns into Josh Rosen no and
here's why because I feel like Haskins
has the confidence of the front office
Rosen lost the confidence of Steve time
and and he never had the confidence of
Kliff Kingsbury when he was brought in
so I don't feel like you know I was
Rosen he was that front office and that
head coach's guy when the head coach was
gone he was no longer that like the cute
girl in school I think what Haskins and
a lot like a change to depend on who
they hired but I really do believe that
he's the front office's guy still yeah I
mean I think you look at it I don't
think they'll hire a coach that doesn't
sign on to develop Haskins I think
that's the most important thing in all
of it right all right final question
draft on draft of the day thanks again
for everyone keep sending those even if
you've already sent one we haven't used
I have it logged will hem Vaughn stupid
great name are the Niners Matt's gonna
like this one are the Niners the best
team in the NFC they're the only
undefeated team right so you are what
your record is you are I think the best
team I think it's Seattle like they're
just playing so well I can't wait to
watch the Niners and Seahawks play
hopefully both teams are healthy because
I'd like the Seahawks were just amazing
right now the other Packers look good I
don't think you can ever count out like
the Eagles the Cowboys I think they'll
get some things figured out the Niners
do look really good but Seattle's the
one team where I would be like I don't
want to [ __ ] with those guys like I
don't want anyone who's back
yeah the Saints like my guy Teddy to
gloves just keeps rolling so hey Kerry
he's driving the bus he's steering the
ship right now keeping it upright that
old 2014 pre drafts got a report on
Teddy's coming in handy right now it's
Undertaker all right that is our show
Connor
some rest on that voice it's usually me
so I know I'm the new you as I as I get
older yeah some hot tea and honey that's
what you have to look forward to we will
be back Friday morning all three of us
God willing with our voices as we get
you ready for the weekend
don't forget this Saturday 9 a.m.
off-the-cuff in Deep Ellum in Dallas
Texas we'll be there pre-gaming and then
watching Texas lose
- oh you yes I'm already depressed it's
gonna be fun oh there will be shots on
hand guaranteed for Connor this is Matt
we'll talk to you guys real soon